la pandemia se agrava en brasil y
contagia a sus países vecinos
uruguay una de las naciones que mejor
atravesó la primera ola sufre un fuerte
alza en los contagios y detectó los
primeros casos de las variantes
brasileñas una situación aún más grave
en el noreste del país y limítrofe con
brasil en esa región piden endurecer los
controles pero lo que se trata de hacer
es un bloqueo de fronteras porque tanto
nosotros como libramiento tenemos un
número muy alto de gente positiva
científicos y líderes regionales han
elevado un reclamo similar al gobierno
de argentina que estudia fortalecer los
controles de seguridad y endurecer los
requerimientos en la circulación de
vehículos de carga y viajeros aunque sin
cerrar las fronteras con su principal
socio comercial más drástico ha sido
colombia que desde febrero ha prohibido
el ingreso de personas desde brasil
[Aplausos]
y es que la principal preocupación está
en la propagación de las peligrosas
variantes brasileñas que en perú ya
tienen una gran presencia y han llevado
a las autoridades a decretar un nuevo
confinamiento en semana santa mientras
que en bolivia analizan fortalecer la
vacunación en las regiones fronterizas
que se está analizando la posibilidad de
que con estas 228 mil vacunas se
prioricen los municipios fronterizos
brasil se ha convertido en el epicentro
global de la pandemia la crisis
sanitaria ha dejado más de 300.000
muertos y ha llevado al límite al
sistema de salud
una situación que llevó al presidente ya
ir bolsonaro a moderar su discurso
escéptico y formar un equipo especial
para abordar el complejo panorama